Monica is with us in San Antonio Texas
hi Monica how are you sure how can I
help starting and so I'm trying to get a
part-time job but really I'm calling in
about my mom so she and my dad always
been a bit strange things to them and so
haven't had a chance to tell them
because they actually move knows in
cities so you know having a part-time
job will be able to visit and such and
trying to find the opportunity but she
let me know that she had ordered
anything see if all these catalogs you
know they also credit and so I'm telling
her I don't want to accept gift because
it was purchased on credit and I'm
trying to explain to her I want her my
dad forget the question is should I
accept these shoes I guess or want to be
her parents and tell her how to spend
the money but sometimes like they've
been very irresponsible during their
lives and I don't want more for them and
she says they're working on it but you
know she's anything like this are you
under 25 I'm not how old are you 31 okay
and so what what what amount of debt
would you guess your parents have ionic
Li have no idea they actually just were
able to sell their house and have
refinanced I don't know how many times I
was really surprised they cannot even
because maybe located to in with my
brother and so surprised even explained
even like I said I have no idea we're
talking really talk about and talk about
it going up so how often does she buy
use how often does she buy you something
[Music]
she
once a month once every six months once
a year probably once every six months
I'd say
okay and it averages like the cost of a
pair of shoes she likes to buy things
that are a little bit I guess I'm
pressing something that I wouldn't
normally buy for myself like I'm more
conservative I like to find things that
maybe like 25 I think 50 dollars and you
know is my limit where I would feel
comfortable finding first shoe she
probably spent more okay so but she's
not spending $2,000 on the over six
months she's spending $200 on you
probably something like that yeah I
wouldn't worry about it I'm not gonna
make a federal case out of a 200 dollar
expenditure your mom has bigger problems
than $200 okay and so when you make a
federal case out of 200 bucks then what
you do is that now if you're out
shopping with her and you're walking
down the mall and you go mom I really
rather you don't do that I love you guys
I'm not really it would mean more to me
that you get out of debt and you start
working real conservatively with your
money than you buy me a gift I
appreciate your sweetheart 1 to buy me
stuff but mom I just really would rather
you didn't today and just if you have
the opportunity in person but like you
know just snubbing her and sending
something back in the mail making a
federal case out of it or something like
that I want you to maintain your
influence with her and increase your
influence and have this conversation
repeatedly but not with you know I
refuse to accept any more gifts and you
know and I would just go mom and rather
you didn't and then with if you're
wither in person make a bigger deal out
of it but that way you can with body
language and tone express love to her
rather than condemnation in other words
mom I don't want you to this because I
love you not because I think you're an
idiot and I wish you'd quit buying me
stuff you know you got to be careful
that that tone doesn't come off that way
you're not doing that but when you're
not doing it in person you have more of
a chance to be misunderstood in the
communication and so I want you to set
some boundaries but be very careful how
you set them so that you maintain
influence with the people you're trying
to convert but you have the hardest
conversion
relational conversion possible at your
fingertips for children grown children
to talk to their parents and get them to
stop doing something is the most
difficult direction of a relational
conversation to get people converted to
do anything persuaded to do anything and
so you know I've got grown children I am
and you know I appreciate them and I
love them but I also remember changing
their diaper and so that just they it's
tough for them to have credibility with
me on some of these things they have to
really work to have credibility and I
work at listening to them I want to be
respectful but I mean you know I've got
a lot of experience and so you know it's
just tougher to listen for parents
listen to kids that's what you're facing
thanks for the call